they never  investigated barack obama for espionage  despite obama gate  now does anybody know what obama gate is  because this is the thing that trump and  others kept talking about obama gate  obama gate no one's doing anything about  obama gate and  when a reporter asked trump  sir with tears in his eyes welling up  with tears they said sir what is obama  gate trump looked at the guy i remember  it like it was yesterday in the press  briefing room and said  you know what it is  you're a reporter you know what it is  what is the crime exactly that you're  accusing him of you know what the crime  is the crime is very obvious to  everybody all you have to do is read the  newspapers except yours  we still don't know what it is but  because trump is now under criminal  investigation for violating the  espionage act  all of a sudden they're talking about  obama gate again obama